[Música]
muy bienvenidos a la entrevistada de
france 24
recientemente se conmemoró el día
internacional de las víctimas de
desapariciones forzadas
hablamos de una problemática que
atraviesa de una manera muy particular a
colombia y es por eso que nos acompaña
blanca monroy ella hace parte de las
mujeres demás japon madres y familiares
de víctimas de falsos positivos desde
hace años protagonizan una larga e
histórica búsqueda de justicia verdad y
memoria por los denominados 'falsos
positivos' blanca monroy muchísimas
gracias por su presencia de frank
crítico es un placer tenerla con
nosotros muchas gracias a ustedes por
esta invitación bueno blanca de los
'falsos positivos' son una herida que
atraviesa en la historia de colombiano
es como se conoce de forma popular uno
de los episodios más crueles de la
historia del país podría contarle a
nuestra audiencia internacional que son
los falsos positivos
bueno los falsos positivos es una
una problemática que hay en colombia que
la hubo en el 2008 por qué razón porque
en el 2005 el señor presidente en el
entonces álvaro uribe
eeuu le pasaba una cantidad de plata muy
grande a colombia para lo del plan
colombia
en esa opción y dejar empezar a ver de
que no habían resultados de que no
estaban dando resultados de guerrilleros
asesinados entonces me llamaron la
atención a colombia qué pasó entre el
señor uribe empezó a exigir resultados
no queremos decir de que él de pronto le
dijo a los militares que tenían que
matar gente pero sí empezó a exigir
resultados de guerrilleros muertos que
hizo el ejército nacional de colombia
empezaron más que todo en la área de
catatumbo en santander a conseguir
campesinos y asesinarlos y hacerlos
pasar como guerrilleros
cuando ya los campesinos se dieron
cuenta empezaron a denunciar ya ellos no
podían hacer esto en el catatumbo en
santander entonces qué pasó consiguieron
civiles
contactaron civiles que llegaran a
a bogotá y estas personas empezaron a
buscar jóvenes de bogotá y no solamente
de bogotá también de antioquia de
córdoba de mejor dicho prácticamente de
todo el país entonces que hacían y le
pagaban un dinero a los reclutadores los
reclutadores llegaban a la parte donde
iba se hacían amigos de los muchachos y
jugar al fútbol todo este tipo de cosas
se ganaban la confianza de estos
muchachos ya luego les les ofrecían un
trabajo ya con este trabajo esto
llevaban estos muchachos a varios
lugares
del país los asesinaban a muchos los
vestían con ropa militar
les ponían ropa nueva encima de la ropa
que llevaban
muchas veces asesinaban jóvenes les
ponían armas les ponían granada les
ponían mejor dicho totalmente para no
alargar más la cuenta ellos disfrazaban
estos muchachos y los hacían pasar por
guerrilleros sabiendo que no eran
guerrilleros y luego ya llegaron a
bogotá
al municipio de soacha chuache es un
poco un municipio de bogotá donde llega
mucha gente desplazada es un es un
municipio del caso de escasos recursos
económicos
entonces empezaron a contactar los
muchachos en el 2000
en diciembre del 2007 empezaron
se llevaron dos luego en enero se
llevaron otros dos luego en marzo se
llevaban otros dos y así sucesivamente
a mi hijo se lo llevaron en el mes de
marzo el 2 de marzo del 2008 fue
asesinado el 3 de marzo al día siguiente
él salió de la casa a encontrarse con
una persona para un trabajo me dijo que
le guardara comida que él no se demoraba
que le iba a encontrarse con el señor
para un trabajo pero nosotros no
volvimos no volví a saber absolutamente
nada mío mi hijo desapareció era como si
la tierra se hubiera tragado
duró seis meses desaparecido no sabíamos
absolutamente nada de él al día
siguiente de haber desaparecido
nosotros con mi esposo fuimos a la
fiscalía fuimos mejor dicho
no nos dan informes ni nos recibían la
desaparición el anuncio de la
desaparición de él porque había que
esperar 72 horas de su desaparición en
todo esos días mi esposo y yo buscamos
duramos tres días a los tres días
llegamos nuevamente a la fiscalía de
soacha ya nos recibieron la denuncia de
la desaparición del y nos dijeron que no
éramos para la casa que ellos no
avisaban si julián aparecía no aparecía
finalmente dura unos seis meses
tremendo blanca quienes eran las
víctimas hablando de perfiles no venían
de regiones humildes de verdad no
elegían a cualquier víctima
ellos elegían a las personas de bajos
recursos económicos nosotros siempre
hemos peleado y siempre hemos dicho
porque no se fueron al norte
por qué no fueron dónde están los
muchachos de una universidad los
muchachos que van a un colegio
de un colegio alto porque no fueron a
estos lugares porque dije se dirigieron
precisamente a su hacha si ellos no
contactaban jóvenes de soacha los
reclutadores iban y cogían indigentes en
el grupo se llevaron a un señor que él
usaba
muletas de 42 43 años se lo llevaron
y lo hicieron pasar como dirigente como
el mandato como se mandara
como si fuera un capitán de la guerra en
todo este recorrido y está lucha
histórica que lleva en adelante qué tipo
de apoyos han tenido por parte del
estado por los entes que toman las
decisiones
nosotros no hemos tenido ningún tipo de
apoyo del estado al contrario llevamos
una pelea ya hace 13 años llegamos una
pelea parda con el estado primero cuando
empezaron la justicia ordinaria donde
llegaban estos militares allí les
preguntaban si ellos aceptaban cargos
nunca aceptaron cargos de lo que
hicieron y luego ahorita ya con la gente
cuando ellos cuando vieron que la
agencia comisión de verdad les iban a
dar un beneficio entonces ahí sí se
acercaron a la gente a decir una verdad
una verdad que nosotros nosotras no
estamos de acuerdo porque se tiran la
pelota los unos a los que hacemos una
aclaración para nuestra audiencia
internacional
la jurisdicción especial para la paz no
excelente encargado de juzgar lo que
fueron los crímenes cometidos en el
marco del conflicto armado a un ente que
resultó no del acuerdo de paz de 2016
entre el gobierno colombiano y la ex
guerrilla de las farc con la creación de
este organismo le da más esperanza a
ustedes de alcanzar verdad y justicia si
si nosotros siempre hemos dicho que la
red es como esa ventanita que se está
abriendo se está abriendo
puesto que en el momento que el ag
empezó a investigar alcanzaron a
investigar 6000
6.402 casos de 'falsos positivos'
pero la suma es mucho más alta es mucho
más alta pero entonces igual manera la
gente cuando empezó a investigar
investigó estos seis mil cuatrocientos
dos jóvenes la muerte de estos jóvenes
que fueron ejecutados por el ejército
nacional de colombia entonces si es es
esa ilusión
eso es lo que nosotros queremos ver una
verdad saber una verdad porque dieron la
orden para el asesinato de estos jóvenes
ahora en junio el ex presidente de juan
manuel santos hizo referencia a lo que
fueron los falsos positivos voy a citar
lo del habló de que era una política de
premiar no las bajadas de guerrilleros
promovidas durante gobiernos de álvaro
uribe santos fue ministro de defensa de
su
gobierno él hizo una suerte de mea culpa
se refirió a ellos como un horror que
nunca debió haber sucedido que le pasó a
usted cuando escuchó esas palabras que
representan para usted santos uribe
estas dos figuras claves no en la
política colombiana sí bastante grave
puesto que cuando todo esto todo esto se
se ejecutó en el mandato de estas dos
personas
bueno el señor santos tuvo ese valor de
demostrar ante colombia ante el mundo de
que los jóvenes no eran unos
guerrilleros
mientras que el señor uribe él no ha
sido capaz de decir de que él dio la
orden y
estamos también detrás del señor montoya
puesto que él era en ese momento el
general de las fuerzas militares donde
él se va la jez y él dice que los
jóvenes de que los jóvenes cuando van al
ejército no saben [__] una cuchara no
saben [__] un tenedor no saben ir al
baño y que ellos ellos salen del
ejército aprendido que en el ejército
fue como
o como una bofetada para nosotros fue
como una bofetada porque siendo siendo
todo un general él debió de haber
admitido y debe de admitir de dónde
venían porque las personas que han ido a
dar la versión siempre lo han nombrado a
él donde él decía que él no le importaba
que ellos cogieron contrabando de
gasolina de lo que quisieran [__] que
lo que le importaba era ríos de sangre
que él quería haber ríos de sangre
entonces esa es la problemática que
nosotros llevamos y la lucha que
llevamos es la lucha de nosotros saber
quién dio la orden de donde adriano la
orden y porque tuvieron que asesinar a
nuestros hijos y hacerlos pasar por
guerrilleros sabiendo que no eran
guerrilleros ya que nos queda poco menos
de un minuto pero bueno antes de
finalizar quisiera pedirle a usted un
mensaje a la población y las autoridades
bueno yo como madre de julián oviedo
monroy como madre como víctima del
estado colombiano yo lo único que pido
es que esto no se vuelva a repetir que
más madres no tengan que llorar la
muerte de sus hijos eso es lo que yo le
pido ojalá más adelante no se vuelva a
repetir está este atroz que se cometió
en el 2008 y que llevamos 13 años
prácticamente ya 14 años luchando por
una verdad me acabo de muchísimas
gracias por su presencia para las 24
ojalá haya verdad memoria y justicia
muchas gracias a ustedes a nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y también en
france24 punto com sigan con nosotros
[Música]